welcome to this second day of the ftth
conference here at Stockland smashing in
stockholm with me i have Gwen cow the
wife to the man we're here all here
because of her husband Charles K cow was
the inventor of the fiber optics as you
can see behind us people are rolling in
here at the exhibition floor lots of
seminars are going on and has been going
on during the morning and even during
the evening yesterday so it's it has
been fantastic days here but this
morning was maybe one of the most
fantastic days for you goin well I was
here representing of being my husband
because he can't come here he couldn't
come here now unfortunately sadly yes
out i'm missing cannot travel now okay
i'm sure you were here for one purpose
what purpose was that to receive his
award for the person who has helped the
fiber to the home project actually
without optical fibers we would not even
been talking about I know would probably
not have been here I mean nobody would
have been here talking about fiber to
the home without the fiber uh unless the
fiber yeah you said your husband has
Alzheimer right he was diagnosing 202
and unfortunately it comes with
longevity one in three when you're over
80 will have signs of some stage of
Alzheimer's so we all have to watch out
for that oh yeah mm-hmm and you also
started a fund 22 yes we started a fund
three years ago that was when he got his
Nobel Prize so he was a famous guy in
Hong Kong and the fact that he has
Alzheimer's made everyone sit up and
said gee see because he uses his brain
too much but actually is a sign of
deterioration of the brain which not
caused by overuse you need to use your
brain to prevent you actually
okay but to get this got the Nobel Prize
2009 that's five years ago mm-hm and
this was for work down in 1966 a long
time ago it's a very notice or Nobel
Prize winners are very very old 80's and
90's have you not noticed and I did ask
them why do you wait for people to be so
old and they said they had to be sure
that whatever they did is had had an
effect and is solid oh yeah so but they
found out about the fiber optics in 1966
when did he start to research about this
I mean this whole 9066 when the paper
was published about the results that he
found about how we could use what we had
to do to make sure that the blast was
pure enough for it to have a low enough
DB loss and all these technical stuff we
did a lot of that sort of research
before he wrote the paper in 1966 and
that's when people read the paper and
says oh wow there's something in this he
must have been very far ahead of
everyone else in the world by that time
at that time yes no one else was working
on on it and he felt it was his duty to
go around to all the various labs around
the world to convince them to do
research on it because one man cannot
change a telephone industry it's a
global it has to be a global effect and
so we had to get the whole world
interested yet he was very diligent in
going to lives in Germany in France in
Japan in the States we were working in
UK at the time so he's been a lot of
years I mean time traveling in those 30
years to get everyone on the bandwagon
did he have that vision already done but
this would be yes he said this is going
to shatter the world oh yeah yep and we
all laughed at him oh you did leaving
you yes no mean how can you believe
someone you know that he's playing at
this work is this work is so much fun
and then he tells you it's gonna shatter
the world you know yeah so so what is
his reactions nowadays when when it
actually happen well it doesn't happen
overnight it took 20 years from 1966 for
these systems to be developed into a
working telephone system for the copper
cable wires why copper wire cables to be
replaced with the optical fibers and
that takes a while to to lay them under
under the sea from long distance and
it's not until all those are they
completely that you can start having
switching over and took 20 years you
know and in the meantime a sort of 20
years he sort of left industry kind of
because he'd been in it for 30 years
yeah and he sort of kind of crept up and
happened but he's enjoying enjoying to
see that the world has changed so much
because of oh yes he did yes he he was I
was before he got Alzheimer's he knew
what was happening and he was very
excited about it all the fiber optics
and the telecom industry has really
changed the world not only for good no
these people are looking into their
screens they're chatting with it with
each other it's changed the world in
more than one way all the big companies
that used to be doing telephone
equipment a lot of them has disappeared
been taken over gone bankrupt in fact
the company he worked for for 30 years
has disappeared completely I think
alcatel bought up part of it and then no
tell bought up another part and then no
tell went into bankruptcy and now we
have all these little new companies
which are very creative and innovative
is spilt a whole brand new industries
yeah that employs armies of people
provides them with an employment
exchange the economies of everything
yeah and even I mean it really changed
the behavior of people and the whole
people are talking to children no
they're not talking to each other have
you seen these young keys to the phone
they're sitting next to each other they
didn't talk no all sort of texting yeah
it's based on or is it bad hi I don't
know it means personal relationships are
not the
many more for the young kids no no have
this Nobel price changed your life in
any way not really we are really quite
old I mean he's 80 last year um and he
in 209 he the effects of Alzheimer's was
already making itself felt so he's not
really enjoyed the fruits of having the
Nobel Prizes Matthew C would have done
if he'd been healthy no but someone said
we are doing good for the world in
another way we're raising awareness of
Alzheimer's yeah so have you been around
at the event laughing gone around and
looked I notice that there's no one from
Hong Kong here the Hong Kong is the
ninety-nine percent 502 the building
where we're a vertical City we have land
imitations so everything we screw up to
80 stories and as they build these new
buildings they just automatically put in
that so the cost is lower Russ so what
is your impression of the event unless
that there's no one else from the new
from hong kong well i noticed i did note
that there it's a couple of people
showing from chinese companies china i
think this one from the big one qui away
from taiwan right yeah yeah so I noticed
they're here yeah you need 27 or
something yessir be no I listen some of
the ones on Thursday they were very
stimulating and interesting and one
thing that made me that I noticed was
what the keynote speaker saying no not
the keynote speaker one of the other
speakers saying the present is already
the future we're just living life very
very fast now yeah Graham thank you very
much for coming to our studio thank you
i enjoyed talking to you thank you very
much
yeah and we're here at the floor of the
ftth conference and if you want to enjoy
the whole conference on your computer or
on your phone you can do it by logging
into FTTH conference dot EU and now with
me i have Espen shagger or how do you
pronounce your ki agar she agar yes from
Norway yes that's right yeah and you've
won the price I did yeah can you tell me
more about the price I will I'm found on
following pages relevant pages on
Facebook and so I found ftdi councils
councils web page a facebook page I want
fiber and I I like that from the autumn
last year and then they announced this
competition from the fourth on November
and at first I didn't bother much about
it because I was busy I had competition
was it was like ok they wanted us to
post a picture or a video showing either
how bored you are when you are waiting
for a slow internet connection or what
possibilities fiber gives you and so a
video of one minute or just a picture ok
and so I registered that but i thought
okay i have work i have small kids I
don't have time for that and I probably
won't win anyways because this
competition have competitions have a lot
of other nobody else anything you know
now that that's the that's the thought
but then as time went by I saw that
there wasn't there weren't very many
participants in this competition at the
beginning at least so I started to think
that maybe maybe I could do something to
participate here and I started to come
up with this idea that me and my brother
could play guitar via telecommunication
oh yeah and I'm sitting at home and he's
sitting playing with me on my 55 inch HD
screen do you have a band together or
something no no we just packed this
together oh just a random songs and just
for fun just for fun and to be close to
your brother yes but the fact is Laurie
he lives 30 minutes drive away from
so this was a most day to showcase yeah
it can be a long time Wade you have kids
and have a job it can it can that's
that's for sure so so so I we did it and
people started liking the video we got
quite a good response and I started to I
hope that maybe I could win this and I
did and you did yes so so no you're
famous famous and famous I there weren't
very many others than my friends to saw
the video ok because i rallied them on
to come to go into the video and like it
oh yeah and so yeah but you can watch it
on on the ftth cat council europe's
homepage or at the I want fiber yes you
can so and and we saw we played
yesterday and we alternated the text so
the lyrics so it was was about fiber oh
yeah so here today all our troubles
seemed so far away comes with fiber
optics here to stay we can sing and we
can play that's what that's what we sang
so there's all of it cheesy but I but it
won me a PlayStation 4 so I'm happy
that's great yeah and otherwise you
could have sung that song what does the
fiber say what does the fiber say yeah
yeah the Norwegian the most famous
Norwegian song nowadays on YouTube is
what does the Fox say I asked that's
true but people are people tired of that
so its SIA I wouldn't do that anyway but
you're working in the fiber industry as
well I am and that's why when I won this
competition I was maybe a bit afraid
that they would take the prize away from
me because I would be disqualified or
cuz i work in the fiber industry but i
do i'm not a technical person I'm i work
as a communications adviser for Lisa in
stavanger norway and leave zones LT box
which is a large fiber provider in no
way okay how large we have three hundred
and thirty thousand customers now on
fiber that's a very impressive yes so we
have a seventy percent of all fiber
connections in no way are ours
and you're just you're still growing in
West move we're growing very rapidly so
in what areas are you growing mostly are
you thinking week you know cities rural
well the thing is with lisa is that we
were first in Norway with the fiber so
we got to pick the the cherry the ripe
cherries low-hanging fruits and so all
the big you know all the big cities and
the the good areas are taken now
primarily by us so now it's more the
rural areas where you see people digging
themselves digging the trenches
themselves to get fiber out of them I
was afraid you that you would said the
rotten fruit was left yeah no it's not
the rotten fruit but it's the higher
hanging fruit stand it yeah more
difficult to get to them now it is there
a demand for fiber in Norway absolutely
the thing is we have a we have a large
customer base and we see that most of
them on mutual when it comes to talking
about fiber because they they get used
to fiber and they they forget about it
you know it's working and it's there and
they don't think about it in their
everyday and they don't talk about it to
their peers because customers are our
most the customers are most important
ambassadors they have to tell their
neighbor that fiber is the only way and
then there is a small group that does
that the positive group and then there
are there's the negative group that says
you know but there's no there's no need
for fiber i can send my emails and and
do what i want check my online bank with
with a dsl or whatever they have yeah so
the we try to try to raise awareness now
that people talk about fiber and it is
the future so that's the main challenge
for you to reach out with the word yes
it's just it's like with electricity we
are an electricity company as well and
people take electricity for granted now
they they switch on the light and they
expect the light to come on when they
switch on the the
the light and and it's the same with
fiber when you start your computer you
you expect the youtube video to stream
immediately with no hiccups no and fiber
is very stable so you rarely get hiccups
as well so people don't don't think
about it it's it flows out of their
conscience anyway so what's the future
for lease and ultrabooks uh well let me
just start by saying the start for it
how we started with it yeah in in
nineteen 1980s we build fiber in our
electricity system so that we had better
connections with you know to have better
control over all the electricity system
over and then in 2000 2001 some bright
minds started thinking how how could we
provide this to private customers and a
small company both of three people was
established in 2001 and the goal then
was to have 28,000 customers by 2017 and
and now we have three hundred and thirty
thousand in the hole in Norway and
Denmark as well that was a really long
perspective for being mean but we're
talking about the dot-com era yeah back
then but but but but that was the thing
that people didn't believe in fiber that
back then they didn't see what what was
the need for such high capacity we
didn't need it they thought back then
but then there were these few people
that believed in it in this end they
started building it and so as the
development been in line near soso been
like a yeah more or less more or less
more or less yes it has you haven't had
this hockey stick yet no and it has been
dependent also because we we have this
partnership alta box is a partnership of
40 different partners utility companies
electricity companies toured throughout
Norway and Denmark that offer out the
box products on their own fiber networks
oh yeah so so Lisa is not the
infrastructure owner throughout Norway
this is just one of 40 partners No so
and that model works very well I guess
because this
factor is that you have to have you have
to have good customer control systems
you have to be able to tackle large
customer numbers yeah you have to be
good at digging and you have to be good
at developing good applications and
services and so power utility companies
handle the two first ones they're good
at digging and they have large number of
customers already know and then we
developed ultrabooks as the company to
develop services so it is work very well
that way ok so when coming to suite and
until stockin's muscle and FTTH
conference what are your perspective on
what you see here for me I work as a
communications advisor so I don't have a
much technical insight into what the
small fiber threads do and things like
that so it's interesting to just look at
trends I think and also when you work in
one country in one market it's easy to
get narrow minded and just look at that
market coming here it's interesting to
race your vision and raise your head and
look at look at Norway in a more
international perspective and see what
other countries are doing and compared
so that'll do you rank Norway compared
to the international markets I I haven't
done any rank personal ranking but I
season always number four when you see
the banners hanging out in the hallway
sire that's good but you're you're
thinking you're a bit ahead of them the
typical European markets country and I
think we've come a long way a very long
way in a way but there's a long way to
go as well I think that's how that's the
only thing i can say kisser I speak for
alta box and lisa and we have very good
progress other other providers are also
now wakening up and starting starting to
go from copper technology to fiber yeah
and and that will help because we cannot
we cannot build fiber norway by
ourselves we have to have all the
providers as well helping us but you
went into to Denmark are you looking to
go into other countries as well not with
not with fiber at this moment we've
started also developing
smart house technology and we have
different countries European countries
looking at us wanting to test our
systems there so perhaps that will be
even bigger than our fiber business case
what kind of services are you looking at
with it with this business we have we
now have to roll out automatic meters
automatics power meters oh yeah and and
in the same roll out we also install a
small computer in every house in our
region 150,000 homes and that small
computer can can communicate with
sensors in the house with the ovens and
lighting and and everything you can
think of that runs on electricity okay
and we connected to the cloud and you
can control everything on your iPad or
your phone and it's a small smoke very
powerful computer that you install in
your fuse box and this could be also
installed in other parts of the country
or in other countries as well so that's
very exciting and this service is
already launched or is it on the table
it's launched in our area so people have
started buying it's what it's called
smartly in Norway so people started
buying it in our area and we're looking
at expanding into other areas in our way
oh yeah and what what is the object or
people do they like it are you using it
we haven't we haven't pulled put full
pressure on the marketing yet because
there are new switches new screens
coming soon which will make it look a
lot better the first launch was a quite
quite dull switches in normal switches
but we have very exciting and good
looking products coming now towards the
summer and so we'll put more pressure on
it then but we launched it just before
Christmas and we have about closing
closer to 10 that and what 1,000
customers about now but but we'll see
that this will explode most probably oh
yeah mmm spen when you have been around
looking at the floor where have you been
to any specific seminar you would
recommend the people to watch in after a
no no
web no just generally I think that
they've been good I haven't been up
Hampton listening too much to the let me
say the detect technique specific
seminars but the more broad seminars the
more you know the more the people that
look on this industry from a higher
perspective those have been very
interesting i think so i want I think
Karen Alice isn't a good speaker it's
very inspiring to listen to her I think
so let just let me get credited to FTTH
council by pulling out her as the
favorite presentation thank you very
much for coming yep thank you and that's
it for this webcast on the floor of the
ftth conference and will be back next
time at one o'clock thank you so much
for viewing this